Thanks to Brilliant for supporting this episode
of Journey to the Microcosmos.
Go to Brilliant.org/microcosmos to learn how
you can take your STEM skills to the next level!
Now it’s not really hard to see how heliozoa
got their name.
With their spheroid body and spiky rays, it
seems almost impossible to not pick a name
related to the sun.
So why not refer back to the Greek god of
the sun Helios?
Of course, heliozoa aren’t exactly riding
golden chariots across the sky, but they’ve
been similarly difficult to pin down.
And that’s partly because we’ve come to
understand that labeling things as heliozoa
might not be as meaningful as we once thought
it was.
In the 19th century, when heliozoa were first
described, the label was thought to apply
to just about any spiky, freshwater organisms
that looked like spiky, freshwater organisms.
The similarity in their appearance suggested
a proximity in their categorization, so it
made sense to group them together.
That has of course changed in more recent
years as scientists have turned to studies
of organisms' DNA to revise those early classification
systems so they better match genetic relationships.
So today, “heliozoa” is less of a specific
label and more of a description, referring
to a set of organisms that are round with
stiff pseudopodia or axopodia, the more technical
term for those spikes.
And they are not necessarily closely related
to one other, they just look like it.
If a heliozoan’s axopodia seem threatening
to you, that’s good.
Those stiff spikes aren’t there as decoration,
they play an important role in the heliozoan’s
hunt for food, whether that’s other protists
or even tiny animals.
And you should probably think of them less
as spikes and more as sticky skewers.
After the heliozoan’s prey gets caught in
the axopodia, it is immediately immobilized
and stuck to the adhesive surface.
The prey then gets drawn in towards the heliozoan
itself until it is close enough to be engulfed
into a vacuole for further digestion.
The central, driving life of the heliozoan
is in that central body, where food is consumed
and the important biological molecules that
keep the organism alive are made.
And what a fine, spherical body it is.
But let’s be honest: it’s the axopodia
that makes a heliozoa so striking to look at.
And for as long as we’ve been looking at
heliozoa, we have wanted to know more about
how those axopodia work and how they’re
made.
After all, axopodia have quite a lot to do.
They’re not simply stagnant spikes on a
heliozoan.
They’re an extension of the organism’s
cytoplasm, carrying the extrusomes that make
their surface adhesive.
And they contract when the organism needs
them to, like when they’re drawing in their prey.
It’s tempting to compare the axopodia to
having just a bunch of arms, but the comparison
doesn’t do the axopodia justice.
After all, it’s not like we can retract
and extend our arms out of our bodies at will.
While axopodia are, in a sense, the cytoplasm
poking outwards, there needs to be something
underlying those extensions to give them shape
and structure.
And that “something” are hollow filaments
called microtubules.
Made from a protein tubulin, you can think
of microtubules as building blocks for eukaryotic
cells, though they’re shaped like rods,
not actual blocks.
Microtubules show up in mitotic spindles,
cilia, flagella, and many other pieces of
cellular machinery.
And how they’re arranged inside an organism—whether
they are unicellular or multicellular—impacts
everything from shape to movement.
And heliozoa’s axopodia are no different.
In the 1960s, scientists wanted to understand
how the microtubules arranged and rearranged
themselves, and how this impacted the heliozoa’s
response to changes in the world around them.
To get a much, much closer look than we can
do here, they used electron microscopy, which
revealed that the microtubules were arranged
parallel to one another.
And when they looked at the cross-section
of the axopodia, they found that the microtubules
formed an interlocking double-coil formation.
But scientists are rarely content with just
knowing the structure of a thing.
They also wanted to know how that structure
responds to all sorts of stimuli.
In the second half of the 60s, Lewis G. Tilney
and an assortment of different collaborators
published a multi-part series of papers titled
“Studies on microtubules in heliozoa.”
We think some selections from the titles convey
the goal of these studies….
We have part 2: “The effect of low temperature
on these structures in the formation and maintenance
of the axopodia.”
Then there’s the sequel in part 3: the “pressure
analysis of the role of these structures in
the formation and maintenance of axopodia”
And yes, there’s a part 4, titled “The
effect of colchicine in the formation and
maintenance of the axopodia.”
That is a lot of analysis on the formation
and maintenance of the axopodia.
And these experiments helped to not only see
what happens to heliozoa in changing conditions,
they helped our understanding of the microtubules
inside them.
For example, when the researchers lowered
the temperature of a heliozoan, they found
that the organism’s axopodia shortened until
they disappeared, a result of the chemical
connections holding the microtubules breaking
down and the structure depolymerizing.
And it was only around 30 to 45 minutes after
the heliozoa were returned to room temperature
that the microtubules reassembled and the
axopodia grew back to their normal length.
This result, combined with other observations
they made with their other disruptions, helped
to solidify the microtubule’s importance
in the growth and structure of the axopodia,
and provided us with more insight into the
cold-sensitivity of microtubules.
These experiments were not the end of the
“poke and prod and disrupt the axopodia”
approach to heliozoan research.
A later study would use what feels almost
a poetic method—or at least as poetic as
you can get with a science experiment and
a microbe named after a sun god.
The researchers subjected their heliozoan
to ultraviolet light, watching as the ends
of the axopodia broke down and shortened,
or sometimes even broke off altogether.
And yet, even then, when the ultraviolet light
had passed, the sun animalcule’s microtubules
were ready to grow once more.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to Brilliant for supporting
this video.
Our speciality here at Journey to the Microcosmos
is talking about the micro sun animalcules
of the world, but what if you wanted to learn
about a sun that’s a bit more macro?
Like, you know, the actual sun.
Well, in Brilliant’s Solar Energy course,
you’ll examine the principal methods of
harvesting energy from sunlight, starting
from fundamental physics principles.
And by the end of the course, you’ll be
able to answer practical engineering questions
surrounding multi-junction cells, material
design, and considerations in servicing utility
scale electrical grids.
Brilliant is built on the principle that you
learn best while doing and solving in real-time.
Since all of Brilliant’s courses are interactive,
you’ll get instant feedback and be able
to learn at your own pace.
If you’re interested in learning more, you
can get 20% off an annual premium subscription
at Brilliant.org/microcosmos.
There’s a bunch of names on the screen right
now.
Those are our Patreon patrons.
Every one of those names is a person who is
helping make this show possible.
So, if you like what we do, they are the people
to thank, and you can learn how to become
one of them at patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes James Weiss, you can check out
Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.